hey everyone its Mike from order flows
and welcome to today's presentation I'll
be talking about the building blocks of
order flow and I'll talk about
especially the Delta surge which is a
specific event that occurs in the order
flow and it occurs you know daily
depending on you know you could use it
on very short timeframes 30 seconds very
you know five one-minute chart
five-minute chart 15-minute chart you
know people always ask you know hey I'm
a more of a long-term trader I'd want to
sit in front of the screen all day I
know is there something that I could
just use on a longer timeframe and the
Delta surge is something that you can
use on a longer timeframe so you know
what I'll be talking about today is
Delta imbalances and point of control
you know I got to cover all three of
those because to me those are the
building blocks of order flow right you
have to know the basics of what you're
looking at to put it together and you
have to know why they matter you know
what they mean what goes into those
numbers and how to apply them now before
I begin you know just understand you
know trading involves risk right I want
you to come in into the you know the
trading world understanding that there's
risk involved you know is it's not a
sure thing you know as much as we would
love to have sure things in life there's
no sure thing in life except death and
more taxes so for those of you that are
new to order flow and you want to learn
more about order flow and give away a
copy of my book that I wrote to trading
order flow is 150 pages you're not gonna
get the hard copy you're gonna get a
link to the download page where you
could go and download the copy and print
it up so you know most people when they
think of order flow they think back you
know 100 years ago - you know Wall
Street's in the 20s you know when
everyone's looking at a ticker tape and
trying to read what's going on you know
nowadays trading has changed it's become
computerized and you know the amount of
information that's out there is just
overwhelming you know it's like trying
to drink water from a firehose and my
goal today is to show you how you can
use order flow in an easy-to-read format
how to analyze it and one
how to apply it to your trading now for
those of you that are not familiar with
me just a brief background since 2015
I've been the owner and trader of order
flows calm which is a software and
education company to teach traders how
to trade how to read the order flow
prior to that I spent eight years at JP
Morgan as vice president of Futures
Trading I spent three years at Commerce
Bank as a UX trader where I traded
blends bauble schastie traded them
against the the US bonds the e-mini S&P
is the Nasdaq you know the five years of
ten years prior to that with Cargill
four years as a trading desk manager
where we literally traded every
commodity in the world same thing at ETF
man I spent two years there and I
started on the floor as a runner with
Dean Witter and I left the floor when
electronic trading started taking
gaining a foothold in the industry right
I realized that you know electronic
trading is gonna be the future and you
know I wanted to position myself that
way so I left the trading floor and I
worked upstairs to trade electronically
so what I did after I left JPMorgan is I
started this company called order flows
and basically what I did is I took my up
to that point 20 years of trading
experience and I wanted to put it into a
software program you know it's hard to
get all your ideas down and put it into
a software so really what I did is I
took you know sort of the core concepts
that I used in my trading career and I
wrapped it around an order flow format
of software way to read the data and I
came up with the order flows trader it's
an add-on for ninja trader 8 now the
charts that you see in this presentation
are generated from my order flows trader
software so basically what the order
flows trader software does is it takes
all that information on the time and
sales right which I just showed you and
it puts it into an easy to read format
now I didn't invent the volume footprint
chart another person did but what I did
is I took it a step further right I put
my own analysis into that chart you know
it's not like Steve Jobs invented the
iPhone what he did or he invented the
iPhone he didn't invent the
phone but what he did is he took the
handphone and he took it to another
level and that's what I'm always trying
to do with the order flows trader you
know I'm always trying to add new forms
of analysis to help traders understand
the market and find better trades and
you know just really briefly you know
other people are using my software they
they're saying great things about it you
know here's a user she says you know
with the order flows traders software
she can see really what's happening in
the market like who's in control of the
market on a very specific time and who's
getting weaker as well but this
presentation you know I'm not really
here to sell you that software I'm
really here to talk about order flow if
you're interested about my software you
can go to my website order flows calm so
what do we know about markets how do
they trade well we know markets trade
through a two-way auction right there's
a bid price and there's an offer price
so for example you know if the market in
the e-mini S&P s this is a little
outdated
twenty nine fifty five and a quarter
versus 2955 offer meaning somebody's
willing to buy it at 2950 five and a
quarter someone's willing to sell it at
twenty nine
fifty five and a half okay but no trades
going to occur unless somebody either
lifts the offer or hits the vid so
what's got to happen right is you have
to have somebody that's willing to say
I'm willing to pay the offer price you
know I'm willing to pay twenty nine
fifty five and a half or somebody that's
willing to say I'm going to sell it at
2950 five and a quarter okay now in
order to do that you have to understand
there's different types of trading
that's going on there's passive traders
there's aggressive traders right the
people that sit on the bid our passive
traders people that sit on the offer our
passive traders right imagine you go to
a car dealer you want to buy a new car
right and the dealer has a list price of
twenty five thousand dollars for the car
but you probably want to pay twenty
three thousand well you want to pay
twenty three thousand the car dealer
wants to sell it at twenty five thousand
you guys are both passive traders in
that respect one of you for someone to
you
the dealer to sell the car or for you to
buy the car has to be aggressive either
if you're the buyer you want to buy the
car you move your bid up right you lift
his offer at twenty at 25,000 if the car
dealer he says you know knows in the
back of his head oh my gosh you know I
got I got ten more cars coming in
tomorrow I got to start moving these
cars he might be aggressive and sell it
to you at the price that you will in a
pay twenty three thousand
all right so passive traders are those
that you know work bids work offers and
they wait for the market to come to them
aggressive traders are those that don't
wait for the market to come to them they
trade at the market they sell into the
bid or they buy the offer now once you
understand that difference that you know
there's there's two different types of
buyers there's two different types of
sellers you have passive trusted sellers
you have aggressive sellers you have
aggressive buyers you have passive
buyers then you can start interpreting
what's happening in the order flow and
what makes the order flow so powerful as
it allows you the trader to see early
signs will move about to happen but you
have to know what to look for now
if you look at a normal foot print chart
without knowing you know what to look
for it's it's going to be pointless
right it's like you know a doctor you go
to the doctor you have an x-ray done
doctor holds it up you look at it okay
that's my rib cage doctor can look at it
oh yeah this is the problem this is a
problem you know he's trained to
understand what to look for in the x-ray
whereas unless you're trained you know
it's to know what to look for in
actually you're not gonna be able to
make heads or tails of it and the same
thing goes with order flow you know you
have to learn what to look for in the
data now the good news is it's not as
complicated as most people think it's
actually fairly straightforward you know
and again it comes down to learning the
basics and the basics are Delta
imbalance and point of controls you know
three things that pretty much all the
rest of order flow once you understand
those three core concepts everything
else really falls into
and it's all the information will show
up on your chart
so Delta is the net difference between
aggressive buyers and aggressive sellers
in a bar all right so if you have
positive Delta you know buyers are in
control at that time if you have
negative Delta that means sellers are in
control and what is doing is its when an
aggressive buyer buys the offer that
registers as plus 1 Delta if an
aggressive seller sells into the bid
that registers as minus 1 in the Delta
obviously if there's no trade going on
at 0 and over the course of a bar you
know with your aggressive buying your
aggressive selling going on
you know however the bar ends up you'll
either have a positive number or a
negative number occasionally it does
fall on 0 but that's just more of
coincidence than anything else but
generally when your bar has positive
Delta it indicates buyers are in control
of that bar and it's usually going to be
a green candle an up candle if you have
negative Delta in the bar generally it's
going to be a red candle is going to
tell you sellers are in control now
imbalances this is what happens between
the two-way auction right we talked
about earlier you have a bid and you
have an offer when you have more
aggressive sellers than aggressive
buyers in the two-way auction you know
one bid at two if you have six buyers at
two versus one seller at one you have an
imbalance because there was six to one
so generally people use imbalances of
four to one as their minimum threshold
you could use whatever you like I know
people that use 10 to 1 I know people
that use 5 to 1 I know people that use
two and a half to one but what's
important is you want to look at what
you consider an imbalance in the market
you know think of it like a seesaw right
you have two evenly weighted people on a
seesaw and it's gonna be balanced but
then another kid jumps on the seesaw
it's gonna be out of balance and another
kid jumps on the same side you have
three kids on one side versus one on the
other you know it's it's imbalanced the
one kid on the other side is up in the
air and the three
they're sitting on the ground and that's
the same thing in the order flow right
if you have you know three you know 300
aggressive sellers versus 50 aggressive
buyers you're going to have a selling
imbalance and it will show up into the
bar the volume in the bar as either a
blue number or a red number now the last
building block is point of control every
bar has a point of control and it's
simply the price level in the bar that
has the most volume traded and if that
can act as supply or you know say
support or resistance over the next bar
I have my software has a special feature
in there where it will highlight special
point of controls which I call prominent
pointed controls which indicate support
or resistance in the near term you know
market turning points all right so one
of the reasons what most traders fail is
they focus too much only on price
instead of what actually causes the
price to move and when you understand
you know those three building blocks
Delta imbalances point of control you
understanding what's causing the price
to move right it's it's caused by buyers
and sellers in the market you know
actual traders making trading decisions
once you understand the relationship
between the buyers and sellers then you
start to understand the market so again
Delta I want to get into Delta now it's
the difference between aggressive buyers
versus aggressive sellers in the bar
positive Delta buyers are in control
negative Delta aggressive sellers are in
control and if you're looking at an
order flow chart you can see markets
moving around you know that's what the
market does it rotates around trying to
find a price where buyers and sellers
can be happy to trade together and when
the market is moving in a direction its
searching for a new level you know a new
balance level and Delta can help you
clue you in and when you know buyers are
coming in thinking oh my gosh this is a
very cheap price the markets gonna go up
right here we are trading sideways for
the most part then we see a nice big
rally you know this is a this is a range
based chart in the
Mini's but you can see here you know
Delta is going back and forth small you
know - 488 - 557 positive 157 - 975 just
9 - 1400 plus a thousand - eleven
hundred - 247 but all of a sudden Delta
gets really big 2368 28 27 6200 as it's
breaking out of a consolidation so I
know that aggressive buyers are in
control of this market then what happens
the market you know puts in a 10-point
rally you know over the next hour you
know this is information that's
available to you if you're not using an
order flow chart if you're just using a
regular candlestick chart this is what
the chart looks like right you can't
make heads or tails you know oh my gosh
so we're gonna put in a big rally I
don't know you know depending on the
type of chart that you're using you know
this is a range based chart you know a
lot of the candles that they look
exactly alike but there's so much
information out there for a trader to
use if they know how to use it you know
here's Nasdaq this is on a 1-minute
chart right we make a new low any time
you make a new low or a new high you got
to ask yourself is this market gonna
reverse or is it gonna keep going in
that direction and what happens at this
low I could see Delta getting stronger
positive right 28 150 - 39 and then boom
it rallies you know in the next bar ten
points on a one-minute chart you know
with the nice strong positive Delta but
the signs were in here in the Delta that
the selling was weakening and the buying
was strengthening this is information
that you can use as a trader to make
better trades you know you don't want
I'm not trying to pick a bottom I'm
letting the market tell me that hey
we're bottoming out here you know the
aggressive the aggressive sellers are
gone and now you're seeing aggressive
buyers coming into the market right you
know if you know everyone is coming in
to aggressively buy you know what do you
think that information is worth to you
is be worth nice trades right that's
that's really what you're looking for as
a trader is you're looking for the
market to tip you off on things
you know here's the Nasdaq again a one
minute chart marketers drifting down
boom it gets the big push down okay on
whatever news I don't care you know I
don't look at the news when I trade I
don't I don't need to because for one in
this market nowadays the markets reacted
before you even get the news but really
what I'm watching is the reaction of the
big traders and what they're doing you
know because the big traders they've got
better news sources than I do you know
when I was working in a bank I had great
news sources now I'm not working in a
bank I don't have access to any of that
information you know I can't just pick
up a phone say hey you know it's Mike
from JPMorgan like I used to be able to
you know what's going on what do you
think of the market know they'll tell me
you know hey this is Mike from you know
trading in my home office what do you
think there's you know hang up on you
but you know trader sometimes thinks
they got to be you know reacting to the
latest tweet you know the latest news
story that's coming across the NBC you
don't need to you let the market tell
you what's going on you know the order
flow information that you're seeing is
the purest form of information right cuz
really what you want to know is what's
happening in the market right now so
what do you have you know you're
drifting lower gets this big push gets
down to a level that buyers say this is
too cheap you know a seller's been
selling but now buyers want to step up
and buy it at this nice little price
here and it just pops back up you can
see the Delta getting stronger 100 to
115 300 and then it makes another quick
10-point rally so that's Delta right now
imbalances again is one aggressive
buyers versus aggressive sellers
outnumber each other by a certain
percentage right the industry standard
is about four to one now again it's not
written in stone but that's the starting
point you know as a trader
my goal is not to say you have to trade
using an imbalance of four hundred four
to one hundred percent you know or you
have to use nine eighty seven to one
ninety seven percent to one no it's
for you to take the starting point do
your analysis find out what kind of
traitor you want to be in the term of
you know how much risk you're willing to
take per trade and go from there you
know that I've worked with a lot of
traders over the years and I've helped
develop a lot of successful traders and
I found you know the ones that want to
be spoon-fed everything are the ones
that don't really make it very far in
this industry the ones that take an idea
a concept that you know a setup like I'm
going to talk about later the Delta
search take that take it a step further
step further and advance it into you
know a full-blown trading plan so when
fine and balances appear you're going to
see on the footprint chart a blue number
a blue volume and for a selling
imbalance you're gonna see a red number
and this is how it appears on the
footprint chart you can see red number
you can see each bars got you know the
volume at price on the bid side on the
offer side so the red numbers inside the
bar is selling imbalances blue numbers
inside the bar are buying imbalances and
you know it's a very quick way to
determine our buyers or our sellers in
control you can see as this markets
coming down you're seeing pretty much
every bars got selling imbalances market
has hits the bottom goes sideways it's
kind of mixed you know you see some bars
with no imbalances then all of a sudden
you start seeing bars with buying
imbalances you know multiple mind
imbalances in there as the market starts
making the way up and one of the
features of order flow Strader software
is it will highlight bars that have
multiple buying imbalances in it you
know just as a visual reference you know
because nowadays we're all a very visual
reference based you know everyone's on
Instagram on Facebook and you know just
looking at pictures all day long and
it's just easy to look at you know a bar
that has a rectangle around it to tell
me that there's multiple selling
imbalances or multiple buying imbalances
of the bar which is information that I
can use as a trader because you can see
all right as this market is going down
it's the low starts going sideways
borrow with Tucson imbalances three
selling imbalances then start sticking
up multiple buying imbalances here
another bar multiple buying imbalances
here for now you know now I'm convinced
that this move down is over because now
I'm seeing the bars with multiple
binding balances spread out in the bars
and you know the market moves higher
this is the euro currency right people
always ask can I use order flow on Forex
on stocks
yes you can you know not just futures
you know I think it works terrific on
futures I'm a futures guy honestly cuz
I'm from Chicago but it also works on
Forex but I think you're better served
watching the forex markets trading on
the CME you know the euro currency the
British Pound the yen etc now again
you're up here or making new highs here
this is gold gold contracts okay again
you know I showed you euro currency I've
shown you Nasdaq showed you crude oil
this is gold it works on you know the
same things the same concepts apply on
different markets and that's important
you know because lots of times people
like to curve fit their analysis on a
market on a timeframe I'm showing you
arranged based charts one minute chart
thirty second chart five minute chart
volume based charts I don't monkey
around with the settings trying to find
the ideal setting for it no it's the
same whether it's a one you know time
frame different time frames different
chart types different commodities or
contracts but what's this market telling
you or at our high of the day right
that's in this green line whereas we
made the new high we got multiple buying
imbalances now we're up here at our new
high I see multiple selling imbalances
coming in right what you got to think
alright I mean people don't like to
think sometimes when it comes to trading
is it's like they want to automate
everything but really the best computer
is the one between your brain one
between your ears right you can figure
out and make the decision for you
alright forget about computerized
trading it computers are there to help
you I don't think you should initially
do your analysis so the smart get we're
at our high we start drifting down I see
start singing selling imbalances and we
start trading down down down down off
our high you know the Delta
getting negative sellers are coming in
at the high this is important
information that you should be able to
use as a trader now one of the important
things of order flow is tells you when
the market is moving fast you know you
want to know when the pace of the market
has picked up and things are moving
pretty quick and imbalances there's a
way to see market sweeps and what a
market sweep is is when a big trader
comes into the market just whacks it
through several price levels and you can
see this is Nasdaq this area here is
what's called a stacked imbalance where
you have more than you know generally
three he could determine how many
imbalances you want stacked neatly on
top of each other
but more importantly you see all these
zeroes in here so that means someone
came in sold it there was no counter
trade that's indicative of a markets we
PC market sweeps happen when there's you
know a data release or a fed speaker
says something or Trump tweets and you
know the algos and/or the big traders
just come in and hit all the bids or
lift all the offers you know depending
on what you know if the news is bullish
or bearish and when you see big long
imbalances in a bar you know that's
indicative of very aggressive selling
occurring in the market yeah and again
this is information that you can use to
your advantage okay and you can just see
how again this is a one-minute chart you
see over the next 1 2 3 4 5 minutes you
know this market dropped you know over
20 or close to 30 30 points in 5 minutes
and but you could have seen it you know
you can't say well I could I would have
missed it you know I would have got in
late now this is a minute based chart
and if you're watching it you'll see
that occur in the market you get short
all right you know that your exit your
stop exit it's just gonna be above you
know this this selling a balance you
know or maybe even a little bit higher
you know above the high of this previous
of the bar with the sound imbalance you
know where your risk is all right and
your potential is boom all the way down
to the low of the day
so the third building back I'll talk
about is point of control now every bar
has a point of control and it's the
level in a bar that has the most volume
and it's important because in a basic
sense it helps you determine where value
is in a bar and if you know where value
is in the market then you can make
better trading decisions right because
if you could determine if something is
cheap or something is expensive then you
know whether to buy it right I I went to
Costco yesterday my wife's like why are
you buying this you know the coffee I
like to buy the the Keurig cup coffees
when it goes on sale normally it's I
think it's like 42 dollars but it's on
sale for $35 right because I know that
normal price is $42 hey I can buy it
seven dollars less I'm gonna buy it you
know just like the laundry detergent
shuts while you buy so much laundry
detergent cuz it's expensive normally
but if it's five dollars off or $4.00
off yesterday
I'm gonna buy it right and point of
control in the bar gives you a reference
point where the most volume occurs
because generally where the most volume
occurs is where people are happy to
trade at that time you know at that
snapshot in you know in this case is a
five-minute bar that you know at this
price like on this big green bar here in
the middle you can see a 3123 that's
where most traders were happy to
transact okay and that's gonna be my
reference point into the next bar and
the next bar and the next bar because
you know oftentimes you know people
always say gosh Mike I wish there was a
way to determine you know why do bars
trade back to a certain level then rally
or trade up to us you know trade back up
to a certain level or then sell off well
oftentimes it's right around the value
area of that bar you know if you ever
done any analysis of market profile and
volume profile you'll understand you
know what the point of control is on a
day time frame point of control on an
order flow timeframe and an order flow
chart is sort of a micro sense okay so I
know that it the point of control of
this bar is the area where most where
everybody not everybody
where it has the most volume all right
so that's my reference point for the
next bar and it's the next bar trades
higher okay I can start getting a bias
that this market is going to start
rallying now you'll notice these bars
you know they come off to a certain
level or then rally they come off to a
certain level then rally
I know pointed controls are moving
higher that's bullish but more
importantly in a lot of these bars
pointing controls holding as support
right holding as support holding as
support you know maybe gets through it
by a tick maybe it doesn't reach it by a
tick but it's coming within a tick or
two all right imagine you know as a
person being able to know where the
market has a high potential to pull back
to then rally from you know where the
markets gonna stop and then continue its
move that's the point of control that's
why point of control is so important to
understand because the point of controls
are moving higher in each bar
if each bar has a higher point of
control than the previous bar it's
telling you the market is moving higher
value is moving higher right in moves
down it's gonna point controls are gonna
be moving down I mean look at this on
this move down or make a new lows but
watch each bar right it comes back to
within you know couple ticks or right to
the previous bars point of control
you know this is signs of what a bearish
market looks like now as this market
starts rallying right we hit our low
we've got these two pointed controls
lined up they're both blue color my
software will indicate pointed controls
that are acting a support or resistance
they'll color it blue if it's support
the color red if it's potential
resistance and they act as turning
points but as you can see as this market
starts rallying point of controls in
each bar are getting higher previous the
bar current bar will come back and come
within you know a couple of ticks of
that point of control so it's holding as
support right it's holding as support
now point of control you know is is very
revealing at certain areas on a chart
right you got to remember you know pull
backs
people love to trade pullbacks you know
here's the e-mini this is on a 5-minute
chart
you know we hit our high but we start
selling off you know oh my gosh you know
I got these red bars you got this
negative Delta this markets coming down
but then I got a prominent point of
control is this blue collar here is
telling me based on the volume of this
bar you know this is where we have the
most volume in the bar you know it's
it's coming in it's lining up with sort
of this previous point of control here
we also put in a lot of volume that this
point of control is probably very
supportive and then what happens the
market rallies up now you could also use
the other parts of order flow analysis
right what are you seeing in the Delta
you're seeing positive Delta here 341
846 mm before you get to the high and
make new highs so you could competently
buy this breakout here to new highs now
the thing with order flow right it's
like cooking and you have the different
pieces of Market Analysis you got Delta
you've got imbalances and you got point
of controls you know that's your
different ingredients it you got put it
together to make you know your your nice
pasta dish right otherwise you know
you're just eating one thing right but
you know why not have a meal make a meal
of the market you know this is the
Nasdaq just a week or two ago this is
from an email I sent out 30 points sell
off right off the high of the day on a
30 second Nasdaq chart 30 points on a 30
second chart the Nasdaq now granted you
know these markets have been very
generous to traders this year I know a
lot of traders that are you know making
their whole the other daily goal you
know in the first 30 minutes of trading
so if you know what to look for right
and here it is on a footprint chart
right if you're looking on a normal bar
chart you know what makes selling this
high any different than the previous
high right this is the move you want you
want that big moved on if you saw the
previous high yeah it made a move about
a eight-point move or get you know
before rallying back up and potentially
when you out but this is the move that
you want right you want those big 30
point moves and I'm not saying you get
30 points but you know if you get 10 15
that's fantastic
but if you're watching the order flow
this is where it gets very revealing so
I say when it order flow is very
revealing to traders you could just see
here or a door hi
all of a sudden you see aggressive
selling coming in you see the negative
Delta starting to grow
you see selling imbalances in these bars
you see point of control 1 2 3 starts
going lower more importantly I'm not
gonna get into it now but there's a
difference between max delta and min
delta but you can see how it's gone from
0 min delta all max delta to 0 max delta
to all min delta this is very important
information as well and then boom you
know you had the 30 point drop right
from here this is these three bars right
here is what you're looking at right
here in the order flow and again it's
very very revealing to a trader you know
order flow is also gonna help you
determine when highs are weak or when
lows are weak right week highs have
mostly negative deltas and sign of
balances are going to be appearing right
yeah we're at this high here and you
know just you know made a new high by a
tick but then you're seeing you know
some negative Delta's appearing up here
at these highs you're at highs you don't
want to be seen negative Delta if you
think the market is going higher if you
start seeing negative Delta's meaning
aggressive sellers under control
you're gonna think the market is getting
heavy right it's going to get ready to
sell off because everyone is selling
right who's buying
well there's buyers but what you have is
mostly sellers right you've seen the
selling imbalances so you see mostly
aggressive selling appearing all right
you see multiple selling imbalances you
know point of controls you know they
they sell off the sell off then the
market eventually will sell off now if
you're at a low you gotta be asking
yourself you know are we going lower or
are we gonna potentially reverse you
know this is one of my favorite trade
setups is when we make new lows and
see bullish points of controls right
primary opponent controls that are
telling me that you know hey there's
support down here you have passive
buyers potentially stepping up to the
market and bidding the market right
there arresting the move down there
sitting there saying you know I'm
willing to buy it down here at this
prices right then you start seeing
aggressive buying coming in in the form
of imbalances right you see this bar has
got one two three four imbalances you
even have a stacked imbalance here then
another important fact is the deltas are
turning positive they've gone from
negative to positive you know and it's
important to watch what's happening down
here these bars as we're coming into the
low - 350 for Delta minus 126 and 16
then you get another push here - 3 3 2 -
130 now it's turned positive and then
it's followed up with another positive
followed up with another positive so
even if you're not convinced off this
you know these 3 bars off the low by the
time you get you know into the fourth
bar or the fifth bar you should be
pretty well convinced in your analysis
that this market has hit a bottom and
what happens is the market rallies
another quick 25 points you know it's 20
points off you know right off you know
the bar off the low but you know if you
still not convinced you still need a
little bit more conviction you just wait
a while you know let the market tell you
that this market is getting ready to
rally alright so the thing that I want
to talk about share with you guys is the
Delta surge you know that's the setup
that you know on my website I actually
have an indicator created for I'm gonna
share with you what goes into it
basically so you know if you're looking
at a footprint shoot chart whether it's
my order flows trader chart or if you're
using sierra chart or you're using
somebody else's chart you know you could
use this setup in your trading and look
for when it occurs and what it is
basically is steadily increasing
positive delta for a buy or for a sell
watch for steadily increasing negative
delta and i should preface that by
saying you know it's over a 4 bars so
the first bar for a buy would be have
negative delta then a positive delta in
the second bar third
we'll have slightly stronger and the
fourth bar will have the strongest of
the four bars and for a cell it'll start
out with positive Delta then a smaller
negative Delta slightly bigger negative
Delta and even bigger negative Delta but
the easiest way to see it is look on it
on a chart so this is charts from this
morning okay this is Nasdaq you remember
right after the cash open the market
just fell over it just fell out of bed
but if you're watching the order flow
it's on a 30 second chart right here you
have the Delta surge right you got this
bar this green bar positive Delta the 58
next bar all right after the cash open -
169 the third bar minus 198 fourth bar
minus 356 where this arrow is this is
the bar you'd be getting short in and it
went from 82 down to 62 in three minutes
all right and you know you could also
take into account what's happening you
got selling imbalances each bars got you
know multiple cell and imbalances in it
and obviously lower point of control so
every all the signs are pointing for the
market to go lower and it just fell out
of bed fell out of bed by over 20 points
in a couple of minutes this is Apple you
know people ask me can I trade stocks
well honestly I say limited to the the
big cap stocks like Apple but same thing
right we just opened right first bar and
got some buying and there you got nice
big positive Delta second bar negative
Delta 10,000 third bar minus seventeen
thousand five five six next bar
seventeen thousand five seventy eight so
it's a little bit higher but then watch
it goes from you know three seventeen
thirty boom all the way down below three
sixteen in two minutes right two minutes
now this is crude oil this is overnight
this is at midnight Chicago time 12:40
it's on five minute chart so say you
know you can only look at longer terms
you know this is a 5-minute chart here
we're coming down we're right near our
lows of the day this red line
is Arlo of the day then it just changes
right here you see the negative Delta 33
then positive 53 117 159 the market goes
from you know the the 70 area all the
way up to the double-o area you know
5570 up to 5600 you know it's a nice
thirty point move over the next hour and
a half and it's a five-minute chart but
how about during that this morning right
this morning around 7:30
we had a surge appear a negative surge
right you had the markets going sideways
right this is how the Delta search how
so how I first started using the Delta
search because I used to trade a
slow-moving grain market and I was
looking for areas where aggressive
buyers are aggressive sellers were
coming into the market okay and this
Delta surge was was the way that I used
to determine that you know buyers were
piling it's solely getting into the
market or slowly getting out of the
market but you can see here 148 130
minus 136 minus 8 96 minus 27 20 2077 as
the market sold off from 55 40 down to
you know the low you know 5555 10 area
there's even one a little bit earlier
than that where you have the at 6:30 in
the morning you know the positive Delta
3 1 3 then - 87 - 357 - 531 then the
market went sideways before the sellers
reappeared and the market again dropped
a quick you know 40 to 50 cents a Mini's
15-minute chart you know people say hey
I'm more of a swing trader you know is
there something I could look at in the
order flow that you know I could use for
my trading now I wasn't expecting such a
big sell-off this morning in the in the
equities but you know you gotta be
prepared for it right here we're you
know we're in a very tight range coming
into the morning you know basically less
than a 10 point range a nine and a half
point range which as you know is pretty
quiet than the S&P 'he's coming into the
morning but you can see the Delta surge
started when we're at our high of the
day negative Delta
bar- delta next bar came back within a
tick of the high- delta the negative
Delta as this market started selling off
right we sold off from basically you
know the 1617 area down to you know I
don't know where we are now I've been
looking at a chart in the last couple
hours but you know if you got 10 points
out of this that's great you know if you
got more than that fantastic
so hopefully by now you can see how
order flow can help you identify trade
direction you know by understanding who
who's in control you can find great
low-risk trades you know don't
overcomplicate trading so for those of
you that have stuck around and are
interested in my book you go to order
flows comm slash book HTML it's going to
take you to a page you have to enter
your name and email address then after
you hit submit it will take you to a
page that you can download the book all
right or you can always shoot me an
email my cat order flow is calm and you
know again if you're interested in the
software you can go to order flows calm
that you know slash special that HTML to
find out more about it but I just showed
you how to use one piece of information
the Delta right there's so many other
ways to use the imbalances points to
control how to combine them to find
better trades so again you know you
could get in my book at order flows calm
slash book HTML and Anna I'll throw it
back to you now